[Music]
day trading it's been all over the news
recently
there has been a surge in overall retail
trading activities individual investors
accounted for almost 20
of the trading volume in 2020. but if i
were to give it a try it's not like i
could actually make any money right
[Music]
even if it looks like there might be
potential day-to-day to make a quick
buck
the stock market over the past year has
looked something more like
this
[Applause]
now while i've started many things
without learning how to do them first
i think this time i'm going to do some
research what is retail investing and
how does it differ from
traditional investing retail investing
essentially just means that an everyday
person
is investing rather than an
institutional investor
for example a hedge fund a pension plan
anyone who is a professional investor
when did this sort of boom in retail
investing begin
robinhood came to the market and offered
free trading called commission free
trading i just bought some stuff zero
commission
so you can trade and you don't have to
pay a fee to do so so what happened in
2019 was some of the more traditional
brokerages like charles schwab
took on that model as well and were
forced to do so and it really just
rippled through the industry so all of a
sudden
you were trading for free so that was
the backdrop and that was the setup
fast forward into march of 2020
you had this historic crash in the stock
market
so all of a sudden you have free trading
combined
with a historic market opportunity
to start investing with all of these
stocks at low prices
and really this retail boom was born
what happened with wall street bets and
retail trading so wall street bets is a
very
now famous you could say uh subreddit on
reddit and it's exactly what it sounds
like
wall street bets they're not talking
about long-term investing they're
focusing
on quick trades to really make a buck
and really what made them so famous
these days
was the gamestop trade gamestop was a
very heavily shorted stock by some hedge
funds
and essentially what they thought was
that if everyone started piling into
game stuff at the same time buying call
options so
betting that the price would rise then
they could force a short squeeze by
these hedge funds and that really is
exactly what happened
the question of whether or not this is
going to be normal these days if the
market
is forever changed as some market
structure experts have put it to me
if you think of the stock market now and
you think of
you say gamestop and what happened there
as gambling and gambling is free in the
stock market and if you believe that
stocks only go up as they have for quite
a while now
then you've got pretty good odds compare
that to
betting in a casino or betting on a
sports match well you've got to pay a
fee still
you have a bookie um so the sense right
now is that
technically you've got free commissions
free trading
it's a pretty good deal compared to
going to a casino or placing a sports
bet for example
all right so i've got some context for
this current moment i should probably
talk to somebody
who actually does this well not only
does trey neil at squirrel trading
day trade he also streams all of his
trades successful or not
on youtube for everyone to see
my name's trey neil i've been day
trading for
just a little over five years now so i
graduated college in 2015.
i started right like when i started my
first job
and i've just always really had a desire
to get
into a kind of job that is
you get paid for how good you are at it
if that makes sense and that's kind of
what drew me
to the idea of the stock market and it's
kind of this
the more you know about it the better
and the better you execute every single
day depends how much you make and or
lose
here we go i got really just deep dived
into it and from there it's just
been something i've been extremely
passionate about what was the biggest
lesson you learned when you first
started day trading
when you first start you think you know
everything right away like in the first
like week or two of you starting to
learn something new you're like oh
yeah i got this i know everything i i
know because you're just getting the top
level stuff
so much of the day trading community
that you're gonna see and read about
online
are those people they're very loud
because they think like they think they
know everything maybe they found a
little bit of success
they've started to make a little bit of
money day trading that's great you think
you know everything and then it kind of
starts to come down you're like i'm not
really sure if i know everything
before it kind of starts to curl back up
remember you are just getting into it
and this is
it's a much deeper rabbit hole than you
can probably even imagine when you first
get started into it this this
this land of understanding the the
understanding how to be a profitable
consistently profitable day trader
you've done some videos on kind of
trading gurus
and uh what differentiates what you do
from what they do i suppose
what gurus do and why why i will start
calling somebody a guru is
if they are telling people if they're
like sending out alerts
to people where to buy a stock right
that is what a
bad guru is to me because they're what
they're doing is they're buying these
stocks they're buying these penny stocks
on low volume
uh they're loading up shares and then
they are telling people that they're
already charging to be on their watch
list they're already making
probably 20 bucks a month from all these
people and then they're going out and
they're telling them hey go buy this
penny stock
because they know that an influx of
buying pressure will cause them to rise
rapidly
so these gurus are buying they're buying
low they're telling all their people and
then they're selling to their people at
a higher price and that is the
negative uh uh guru connotation more so
than just selling the course i mean go
out
go out get your hustle if you want to
sell a course you want to sell a course
get your hustle make your money
i don't really mind people people are
choosing to pay for that right they're
not
that the whole con man part of it is
kind of what i uh described formally so
so if i'm going to really get into this
how do i get good at it uh well the
first step
is to go ahead go ahead and open up a
brokerage and there's plenty of
different ways you can go about it
td ameritrade has one of the better ones
with thinkorswim
and we don't need to get too much into
specifics but just go ahead and open up
a brokerage just about all of them will
offer paper trading
and paper trading is the ability to
trade the stock market without real
money right without actually having to
put
any kind of your hard-earned money on
the line and then start educating
yourself and i guess whatever media that
you find the most palpable right
i make youtube videos go to squirrel
trading watch my videos i can show
myself
uh but there's there's all kinds of free
content on youtube
there's all kinds of books you just
google anything you want to google
investopedia is a great online website
there's plenty of books around the
mindset of a trader which i think
is something very very important that
you should focus on try to stay away
from
trying to learn all too many strategies
you can kind of get yourself an analysis
paralysis
go out there maybe find one one quick
strategy if you
youtube search day trading strategies
for beginners you're gonna get an influx
make sure before you start trading with
real money i mean just make sure you
have
a real sustainable profitable strategy
and outlook on the market say
just go a month or two in which you have
made money in paper
and then you can start to put real money
in because it's very different when you
start to put real money in
any any trader out there will tell you
that paper trading is a lot easier than
real money trading just because of the
emotions involved so
just be safe when you get into it at
first please please paper trade first
and and then don't just don't think
you're gonna go into it it's not a get
rich quick scheme
something that's going to take you a
long time to build up the processes and
education on
all right so trey's probably right i
should open a paper trading account so i
don't have to start by committing
anything real
i think i'll buy million dollars worth
of
henry co what a great name that must be
a really great company
while i cannot stress enough that we do
not endorse
day trading it has become a hobby for a
lot of people
so before you get started do some
research start a paper trading account
and always be aware of what you could
lose
now let's check in on those shares of
henrico
oh oh no
[Music]